construye un hexágono regular inscrito
en el círculo lo que voy a hacer es
dibujar una regla y voy a poner una
línea que pase exactamente por el centro
de esta circunferencia la voy a hacer
horizontal ahí está ahora lo que quiero
hacer es tomar el compás y dibujar una
circunferencia que sea del mismo tamaño
que la circunferencia original y lo que
voy a hacer es poner el centro de mi
nueva circunferencia aquí en donde esta
línea intersecta a la circunferencia
original y aquí a su vez esta nueva
circunferencia pasa por el centro de la
circunferencia original aquí lo
interesante es que si yo tomo una regla
y uno este punto con este punto de acá
en esta intersección pues voy a tener
aquí un segmento que me dio un radio
estas dos circunferencias miden lo mismo
son del mismo tamaño por lo que este
radio es igual a este radio de acá y si
uso otro segmento y uno
este punto con el centro de la
circunferencia original también medirá
un radio aquí tengo un triángulo
equilátero ya que cada uno de estos
lados mide lo mismo me piden un hexágono
voy a tener seis lados y curiosamente
este arco de aquí me de 60 grados ya que
los ángulos internos de un triángulo
equilátero miden 60 grados cada uno ya
que la suma de todos sus ángulos
internos debe dar 180 grados 60 x 6 me
va a dar 360 que es lo que mide la
circunferencia total así que aquí ya
tengo un lado del hexágono bueno que más
necesito hacer pues puedo hacer lo mismo
dibujar este triángulo seis veces y
tendré mis seis lados utilizamos la
regla para ahora unir esta intersección
de aquí abajo con este centro y también
uno esta intersección con esta otra de
aquí abajo y ya tengo dos triángulos y
dos lados de mi hexágono así que aquí
puedo hacer lo mismo del otro lado para
tener también otros dos lados del
hexágono
vamos a usar el compás nuestra
circunferencia nueva debe ser del mismo
tamaño que la original más o menos si lo
tomo ahora de manera que coincida el
centro de la nueva circunferencia que
toque la circunferencia anterior y
viceversa que la circunferencia nueva
pase por el centro del círculo original
y hago lo mismo incluso no tengo que
estar dibujando todos los triángulos
interiores para el hexágono nada más me
piden que dibuje el hexágono así que
puedo reutilizar por ejemplo esta línea
y puedo unir este con este puedo
reutilizar este otro segmento que tengo
acá donde manera que una esta parte con
esta otra intersección de aquí abajo que
de hecho no tuve ni que cambiarle el
tamaño ya venía igual y aquí tengo uno
dos tres cuatro lados de mi hexágono
para tener los dos que me faltan solo
necesito unir estos segmentos de aquí y
el segmento de aquí abajo también y así
tengo mi hexágono
seis lados iguales a dentro de esta
circunferencia